hello and welcome to this video playing
Mar without f you know maybe maybe I
should hmm
find different recording time in my
videos I really have a problem them with
the opponents ratings I keep getting
relatively low rated opponents and I
don't mind to play a range of opponents
but it's really rare to have opponents
that are my level or above is basically
it doesn't happen so it's it's a little
bit it's a little bit of an issue maybe
I have to switch to a different time of
day
I currently record the videos in the
morning hours yeah which doesn't mean
that I'm winning this game easily or
whatnot yeah I'm not trying to say that
it's just like sometimes the games I
have a lot mismatched really just that
I'm saying that i blundered because he
might have f5 now that could be
dangerous
we didn't play it hurt maybe I was lucky
damn okay we had a 1 f for opening and
you might be surprised to hear that I'm
quite happy with my position I don't
have much space but White has some yeah
White has made a couple of moves that
weakened his position it's got f4 d4 and
so on and orders a little bit weakening
and I have a little bit less space but I
have good pieces oh that's surprising so
how do we take the surprises or why I
think I'm better now as I get the e4
square I think I'll do hmm don't use him
I think I want to e-file open both
captures were fine I guess
idea now is to jump into okay awesome
maybe it wasn't hanging but it's really
it's no no we used to be too fancy about
it so it looks nice but how do we
continue them I can play h4
he cannot move the age for now so okay
is there anything if I have no d5 I can
tinker with the rook okay so get this
now King g7 just being ready for rouga
Jade if necessary here with her inside
what's that all that great oh he allows
me to take that interesting if I take it
I've takes this Bishop h6 yeah maybe I
actually want to avoid that well not a
good idea maybe at this particular
moment
currently he cannot take on h8 and
playbook h1 because I take and then g3
hangs so I don't see an obvious way for
him to continue here to simplify matters
an idea is always to just bring the
knight back and try to trade it on one
of those two squares like an either like
this that looks funky yeah trying to
trade this one I came just retreats I
can go c5 this was something that I was
thinking about if this is helping me
maybe I'm actually able to take and
place the phone and let's do that take
and play see phone for Queen c6 I can
play Queen c6 immediately actually maybe
this is better yeah why not why not this
is why why is that working I can take it
right
I mean how many pieces on the diagonal
but it ultimately is quite threatening
not certain night here 92 92 Wenzhou not
92 overtakes it I win 21 maybe
yeah maybe not the best one now that's
bad move really
what was that thinking yeah even Queen a
three SS interesting try to play Queen
or this one and now it's got bishop to
deform
I should I should make a good move once
in a while at least
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you know that that was really not
well played yeah he shouldn't have an
ending it really shouldn't something
that should have been ended by by made
or winning winning the house yeah I mean
I think I was better but not a good way
to convert this yeah so we had this on
the board and I got to check in him
after which defaults the only moves to
not lose the beat who pawned and now I
play didn't know quite quite simple
fashion simply trading off this Bishop
and then putting on every single pawn on
light squares oops
you had to compliment my bishop so that
will always be a very compact position
yeah this is basically looking like a
kurakin Scandinavian type of game where
he has played f4 which is not really
useful so I think I'm I'm okay here
nothing special
but maybe maybe my next move was a
mistake that's very much possible
because um Knight c4 Queen c7 I think
he's got f5 and the engine agrees f5 is
a problem and I'm not entirely certain
what I would have played to be honest
because it looks so dreadful and the
engine wants to do this
tonight would be seven whoo yeah that is
not good
yeah if I was strong that was just wrong
I should avoid 97 I mean probably a
normal move like this and yeah I think
it's quite okay the engine likes white I
mean the space is important and they
have a bit of a problem to get the
brakes and I would like c5 maybe he's
better that's possible you can even
think about this that would also solve
the issue of the somewhat somewhat bad
bishop now it's possible you know so we
we got this which is still of course
okay but he should absolutely not take
that's a huge strategic mistake he
should yeah drop back to G to F - G - o
a three and then we have gather position
type mentioned where I'm probably play
this where I'm solid but I don't have a
clear way to improve the position now so
I'm surprised that the engine is liking
white that much but okay
he took a five and now I'm better it's
just the big square only for this this
is just too much it's just too much
okay I'm reasonably happy up to this
point but H 4 is probably not great yeah
it's not great engine wants to take even
yeah I mean it is always must be better
for black to some extent I couldn't
quite well it didn't like I was quite ok
like up to this point with my play but
now like c4 is not not a good idea
it just has little value to it
yeah I thought you would go bishop
before I mean it is better for black
yeah but he gets some checks and Jim and
then after Queen d7 I was basically
saying okay give me the endgame at least
then I have an easy way have easy moves
let's say and cannot screw it up you
know he cannot go there the cause of the
check I believe he only has one check
here so let's say King here and rookie
one should win and I think yeah make
sure it wins yeah and then the ending is
excellent yeah and oh hey I made a
mistake the actually he's got he's got
g4 here yeah yeah again I wasn't
entirely happy with what I did you okay
guys thanks for watching